we're hearing from the two astronauts
who made history when they splashed down
in the gulf of mexico on sunday
it was the first splashdown for nasa
astronauts in 45 years
this was also the first time a private
company has taken humans into orbit
and returned them to earth as mark
straussman reports bob bankin and doug
hurley said their spacex capsule came
alive
during the ride home space history
fell from the sky splashdown
and into the gulf of mexico welcome back
to planet earth and thanks for flying
spacex
the first crew to complete a commercial
space flight
we felt the splash and we saw it splash
up over the windows
it was just a great relief i think for
both of us at that point
inside the bobbing spacex capsule bob
benkin and doug hurley
reached for their satellite phone hi
this is bob and doug we're in the ocean
and then we also called our our wives
who happened to be together i think they
were here
at mission control and of course they
were excited
too excited a flotilla of pleasure
boaters they ignored coast guard
warnings
and surrounded the capsule there's some
safety aspects that i think
we'll have to take a look at because it
just can't can't happen like it did
before
the capsule was charred from its fiery
return through earth's atmosphere
banking described the way crew dragon
roared to life
it doesn't sound like a machine it
sounds like an animal
coming through the atmosphere with all
that all the
the puffs that are happening from the
thrusters and and the atmospheric noise
they named their capsule endeavor just
like at space shuttle namesake benkin
said their ship could someday
land in a museum i think all this this
hardware
has a home someplace in the future when
it's used up
it's just not used up yet the next to
fly it
benken's wife astronaut megan macarthur
next year for cbs this morning mark
straussman
atlanta